[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to update 9.0 it's been nearly a
year since i did my last numbered update
video as you may remember that was
update 8.0 in august 2012 but without
any further ado this is update 9.0 now
you might have noticed a short gap
between this video and my last video and
that amount of time was basically filled
with me going through a sort of a
cleaning and
overhaul sort of behind the scenes
process so i was going over the
efficiency of the way i make videos i
felt like it was a little bit
inefficient before now i've added a
couple of tools to help me make that a
much smoother workflow and that's
basically what i've been doing for those
past couple days i also made some behind
the scenes changes in terms of like
studying what sort of style video i want
to keep doing i love the style that i've
been working on i've been working
towards a certain look of the way i do
video but i've also been uh watching
some other people's videos that happen
to be excellent and a whole bunch of
different stylized things so that
basically involved a whole bunch of
watching youtube videos vimeo videos
downloading a whole bunch of different
effects and animations and transitions
and things like that to help me get an
idea of what i want videos to look like
but that's what i've been doing for the
past couple of days but now that i'm
back now that i'm back in full force i
figured i would uh pull for some faqs
some frequently asked questions so
without any further ado these are the
most frequently asked questions that
have showed up in the past couple of
years actually in the mkbhd inbox a lot
of these were recently pulled from
twitter i asked you guys at mkbhd on
twitter uh what questions you guys had
to ask me and so that's where my notes
are here on my phone so i'm going to be
reading them uh and i guess my answers
to you just right off the top of my
chest so the first one is what's the
setup behind you like and am i still
using the hackintosh pro uh yes so the
setup behind me gets probably the most
questions out of anything
and i do hope to do a 2013 setup tour
project similar to the compilation i did
in 2012
but in terms of just what's always
behind me in my videos i do still use
the 30 inch dell ultra sharp monitor
with the portrait 20 inch beside it and
it is still flanked by those red and
black ikea audio m505 v2 studio monitors
and yes the hackintosh pro is still
running the show so that is what's going
to be my editing machine and it has been
since i finished the hackintosh pro
project video series now the mac pro is
coming out very soon the new 2013 little
trashcan looking darth vader mac pro
and so that will have the opportunity to
run the show we'll give it a full fair
shot and see how it goes uh but until
then and as of right now it's the 2013
hackintosh pro what am i currently
studying and why
i'm currently studying business and
technology i'm a junior in college this
upcoming year 19 years old
on i'm studying business and technology
that's my major i'm also studying a
little bit of marketing and a little bit
of information systems and why
that's just because that's what i'm
interested in that's what i like to uh
study and this is probably the first
year uh my third year in college that i
really get to pick the exact courses to
be specifically what i'm interested in
so i get to really fine tune what i
learn about this year and that's that's
definitely good so i'm studying it
because that's just what i like what
camera and equipment do you use um i
actually get this question a lot
probably more than any other of the
questions that i get uh so i actually
took the liberty of putting together a
list on amazon i'll have it as the first
link below the like button of all the
basically the core of the video
equipment that i use to shoot and
actually edit my videos so the software
and the hardware that goes into the
production so that's the camera the lens
microphone all that kind of stuff and
that'll be the first link below but
basically i've been using the canon 5d
mark iii for a little bit now and it's
become easily the favorite tool in my
bag but i have some other updates about
that to show you very soon so i'll be
sharing that with you also why don't you
use iphones or do reviews of them uh
well i just happen to have been using
android for a very long time now uh but
about that it's funny i did try the
iphone 5 for a little while uh and you
can probably ask tld today to vouch for
that because i bought his iphone uh but
i i don't really use ios for the same
reason i don't use windows phone much
and that's just because i don't find the
same level of customization i tend to
like to make my phone my own and that's
why i did the what's on my android
series but
yeah there's not the same level of
customization on windows phone or
blackberry or ios you tend to look at
those home screens and they all look the
same but that being said i am giving it
its fair shot i do have some windows
phone flagships in the house so that
will be uh very soon in the review
series and also i i definitely plan on
giving ios 7 a full hands-on try we'll
see what the next iphone is like i'm not
that excited about it because i know
it'll be very similar to the iphone 5
but that's the answer to your question
why don't you game
well i rarely game that's a good
question because i don't really ever
review anything gaming related because
i'm not a big gamer but when i do game
uh it's racing games it's driving games
driving simulators racing simulators
need for speed forza that type of thing
that's the only way i've ever enjoyed
gaming really
and now i don't actually own any gaming
consoles i have a tv that i've played
games on but it's connected to a
computer not a gaming console so if you
guys want to suggest ps4 or xbox one for
me as someone who has never really
played a lot of console games let me
know in the comment section below i can
already see a war starting out but i
honestly i just play racing games that's
basically it that's what i find fun
what's a great 1080p camera for starting
out on youtube uh my personal favorite
recommendation is the canon
elph-300hs it's a compact camera so it's
a point shoot and it takes great stills
but it's also very affordable very well
built takes 1080p video and takes
quality video so it's a good stuff it
has a wide angle lens on the front too i
believe it's a great recommendation for
starting out in any sort of media
creation experience especially for
starting youtubers if you had to pick
one smartphone to be your daily driver
what would it be
oh wow that's a good question um
i because obviously i don't really use
one phone for very much longer than a
couple of weeks i tend to hop around
based on the scenario but you know if i
picked a single daily driver i would
have to go with the galaxy note 2 and
now it's not a 1080p display and i do
love pixels and i'm really disappointed
that there's no note 3 yet but
that's the only phone with lte whose
experience i really enjoy that lasts
longer than i needed to so that's the
battery life
key factor there
the razer max hd is not really fun to
use for me so i would say the galaxy
note 2 i would be fine with using that
as my only phone if we went back in time
which phone would you have wanted to be
a google edition phone
wow that's a great question uh
the google edition program of phones is
very new we have the sony one the htc
one the samsung one
ah
wow i i would i would pick the galax
actually no i'm gonna go with the
samsung galaxy s2 because i use that
phone on verizon and i really loved it
but that was back in the time when
touchwiz was really bad that was i think
android 2.3 uh touch was just a mess
back then and i would have loved to use
a phone like that with a nice battery
life and one of my first uh positive
experiences with an oled display i would
have loved to see that phone run stock
android and of course that was back in
the time when if you were into android
you would root and install an aosp based
rom anyway
but uh enough jargon aside i think the
galaxy s2 would have been a nice phone
to see as a google edition who do you
like better duncan 33303
or me this is from
lamar wilson
i'm not gonna answer that i'm not gonna
answer that features i am expecting in
the upcoming android 4.3 update
uh you know i'm not expecting a whole
lot of change actually with the android
4.3 update i did a video and in the
video i did about uh the way google is
taking back android and delivering new
updates and new features via the play
store rather than over the air updates
uh it seems like the next big update we
see with android in terms of features
will be android 5.0 rather than 4.3 so
in the 4.x category of android i'm
expecting to see more and more
incremental improvements performance
improvements little functionality things
here and there there's some rumors about
uh some improvements with the
notification panel for example some
notification say shades stuff uh and new
apis there so that could be interesting
to see how apps tie in and plug into
that but right now i think uh android
4.3 is just gonna be a lot more under
the hood stuff and i'm totally fine with
that best in-ear headphones for under
100 bucks
clips s4 those are nice and best
over-the-ear headphones for 100 bucks
i'm gonna go with the grotto sr80is for
that loved them
uh that's it those are the questions
that i'm answering if your question
wasn't answered feel free to you can
still shoot it to me at twitter at mkbhd
that's where i got a lot of these
questions from and also facebook but
i'll have all the social media links
below like where they usually are and
all the stuff i mentioned in this video
will be right below that like button but
either way that's been it i am back back
in full force more reviews more
explained videos more technology all
kinds of stuff like that is right around
the corner coming very soon in the next
few videos so stay tuned for that
subscribe if you haven't already and i
will talk to you guys in the next video
[Music]
you